yes the health secretary has defended
his handling of the pandemic
and denied explosive claims he ever lied
to the prime minister
that allegation was made by boris
johnson's former advisor dominic
cummings
but during almost four hours of evidence
to mps matt hancock said it was telling
that mr cummings hadn't followed up his
claims with proof
mr hancock had also pushed hart back
hard on a claim he made earlier in the
pandemic
that a protective ring would be put
around care homes to prevent a high
number
of deaths among the elderly his response
was simple
and somber we tried more on that in a
moment
let's take you through some of the key
pieces of evidence mr hancock gave to
mps
he denied dominic cummings claim that he
had repeatedly lied to the prime
minister throughout the pandemic saying
he always acted with honesty and
integrity
mr hancock also said that the government
had followed clinical advice on
discharging patients from hospital into
care homes
and said that every care home death
weighed heavily
the health secretary said he regrets not
challenging advice from the government's
scientific advisors sage
that the public wouldn't comply with
lockdown rules which led to a delay in
the country locking
he acknowledged that getting hold of
enough personal protective equipment or
ppe
had been a challenge but denied there
was ever a shortage
first though the question of whether the
health secretary had told
untruths did you ever say anything to
the prime minister that you knew not to
be true
no thank you and specifically in terms
of the
the particular points that dominic
cummings raised
uh first did you say that everyone who
needed treatment
got the treatment that they required
when you've been told by the chief
scientific advisor and the chief medical
officer
that people did not get the treatment
that they deserved
i did absolutely say both in private and
in public
that everybody got the covid treatment
that they
needed and i'm very proud of the fact
that with the nhs
we delivered on that during the pandemic
because it was critical that earlier
evidence from the prime minister's
former advisor dominic cummings loomed
large over today's proceedings
he was asked to comment earlier on mr
hancock's evidence when are you going to
um provide the evidence for the
allegations you have here to health
secretaries
so no response from dominic cummings but
his claim that he repeatedly called for
the sacking of matt hancock was brought
up today
but the health secretary quizzed over
why there appeared to be so much
animosity between the pair
i have no idea i mean i i just
you know i worked directly with the
prime minister from the start of this
and of course i worked with his um his
aides and his team as well
and um i i have no idea
did you know that he wanted the prime
minister to fire you
uh yes because he briefed the newspapers
at the time right
or somebody briefed the newspapers i now
have a better idea of who it was
and did you raise an objection to that
yes of course and i had the prime
minister's hold some support all the way
through
well let's speak to our deputy political
editor sam coats who's here
uh sam this was the health secretary's
chance to defend himself defend his
handling
of the pandemic and to come back against
those explosive claims made by dominic
cummings how did he do
well there was two parts to today
session really there was the dictate
the agenda as dictated by dominic
cummings in his explosive evidence
session
uh a few weeks ago and on those issues
as you heard really the committee didn't
get any
uh joy they didn't get any specific
answers
matt hancock rejected the claims of
dominic cummings and effectively the
committee
allowed him to move on the real meat of
today's session however were the
questions that the committee had about
the serious challenges
even perhaps the errors that the
government made in the handling of the
pandemic
and across four and a quarter hours matt
hancock was drawn out in detail
uh on those things the charge sheet
against government
even from this committee which has two
conservative chairs
appears pretty substantial the committee
fears that the country locked down too
late last year
that there wasn't the testing capacity
and probably put people back in care
homes
even though they were testing positive
from hospital
matt hancock didn't really reject those
claims outread
outright instead appeared to try and
want to explain
uh contextualize in some cases point the
finger of blame there's a lot in there
i think that will be chewed over for
some time to come one of the most
extraordinary
things he revealed was that right at the
end of january so
nearly two months before the country
locked down he got advice
that under the worst case scenario there
could be over
uh 200 000 deaths uh sorry 820 000
deaths
based on modelling let's hear what matt
hancock said he was told at the end of
january 2020
the challenge in those early weeks of
march was making a
massive judgment probably the most
significant judgment that any prime
minister has made
in certain peace time based on
incomplete information and a great pace
so
i instructed the department and the
health system
to plan on the basis of a reasonable
worst case scenario in january
in fact on the 27th of january and
on the and i asked for a reasonable
worst-case scenario planning assumption
and i was given the planning assumption
based on
spanish flu and it was signed off at
cobra
on the 31st of january and that was a
planning assumption
for 820 000 deaths
and i was determined that that would not
happen on my watch
sam this is a lessons learned committee
hearing what did the health secretary
say about where he thinks things went
wrong
well it was interesting there were lots
of different places whether blame lies
not all of it
or not much of it it would seem in his
department for instance he blamed the
global
scientific consensus uh that suggested
he said until early march that there was
no
asymptomatic transmission from
chronovirus listen to what he said on
that
the who's position was that and i quote
there has been no documented
asymptomatic transmission now as i say
given all of this and this debate and
it's an absolutely accurate reflection
of the
of the debate i regret that i
i should have stuck with my guns and
said well
there is even if it's uncertain and even
if it's relatively small
we should base policy on that um because
even though the the advice i the formal
advice i was
receiving was that it is asymptomatic
and transmission is
um is unlikely and we shouldn't base
policy on it
and that was and and i should have
overruled that
so matt hancock saying a slow to lock
down because
of the global scientific consensus worth
saying of course that the sage advice
was pointing out
that there was a transmission without uh
symptoms uh
as early as the late as late january so
i suspect that claim will come under
scrutiny mahankar also said that he
should have challenged the consensus on
sage the uk
government advisory body that you
couldn't really do lockdowns in the uk
uh in the same way that you could uh in
asia uh i think that
one of the two key areas also that will
be picked under
uh picked over will be his claim that
despite all of the problems with ppe
there was never a national problem with
it
uh just local uh some local supply
issues
uh and he also claimed that that didn't
lead to anyone uh
dying i think there'll be a lot of focus
on that and he also appeared to play
down the problem
of infections in care homes from
hospitals you'll remember many
patients sent home at the start of the
pandemic in order to free up beds in
hospitals
uh only to find then that uh care homes
for a lot of cases of coronavirus
he insisted that something like only one
point six
six percent of cases uh actually came
from hospitals greg clark
one of the co-chairs of the committee
really challenging him uh on that figure
suggesting that a lack of data
meant that the figure looked lower than
it really was so lots of uh
different issues to chew apart it wasn't
as explosive as dominic cummings set up
today's session to be
but the nature of the pandemic its
complexity means that actually to get to
the heart of the issues you needed a
much more detailed session like the four
and a quarter hour one that we had today